let's see who else is on the phone at 6
1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let's try a caller this
is crazy now we're going to country code
92 I have no idea what this is but let's
go to country code 92 me yes it is who's
this where are you calling from oh hi
there my name is usman I'm calling from
Pakistan how are you and please just
take the phone a little further from
your mouth so you'd come through a
little more clearly is it a no yes thank
you okay I just wanted to say that I'm a
very big fan of you I've been watching
you since I was 14 years old
amazing now yeah so I really like her so
you you were like the first progressive
youtuber which I started towards you and
Kyle Kerensky this is incredible they
will ask you my friend are in in
Pakistan our American progressive
youtubers known at all like are you able
to go to someone in your community and
say hey did you see that
Kyle kolinsky clip and like someone else
would say oh yeah I did see that like
are they are these channels at all
followed in your country no they're not
you're the only one you don't talk about
politics much with my friends okay
so although my dad just progressed a
progressive he used to be a socialist
doing his college days so I talked about
politics with them we're gonna need to
pull the phone much further from your
mouth because you're coming through so
distorted but I would love to get a
question from you if you're able to just
just keep pulling that phone away from
your mouth okay is it better now yes it
is okay I just wanted to ask you how
would you respond to the team
that VH label is slavery
so y'all so he'll damn attack yes I
normally prefer socialist see that Beach
Beach label is some form of exploiting
of a very case so how would you respond
to that well already you've sort of
you've gone from saying wage labor is
slavery to wage labor is exploitation
now those are two very different
scenarios I completely reject the idea
that wage labor on principle is slavery
however there is no doubt that there is
some degree if we define exploitation as
someone who establishes the factory is
profiting from the labor of someone else
then that is a form of exploitation now
we might say that if the working
conditions are good if everybody has
good benefits and is paid a fair wage
that that surplus that the capitalists
to use Marxist language earns from the
the wage laborer that it is a fair
exchange for taking the risk of
establishing the factory and buying the
capital and the machines and
establishing human reach you know all of
this different stuff human resources etc
so slavery I would say absolute
that'sthat's not you know of course we
can find situations where there is
slavery indentured servitude and I'm
against those the idea of exploitation
we're now talking about ok what is a
fair amount of profit for the capitalist
in exchange for creating the factory
risking their capital employing other
people etc and and then you're already
talking about a gray area if that makes
sense and that that area is where social
democracy essentially operates what is a
fair amount of profit for the capitalist
and what should they be required to
provide an exchange to ensure that
people have a living wage and the social
safety net yes
can I ask you just one final question my
pleasure
in America are there any progressive
governor's like that you admire that
share our ideas as progressives there's
no one that shares all of the ideas but
you know with so jay Inslee is really
good on climate and you know you you can
sort of pick and choose from different
governors uh what what you like listen I
so appreciate your call from Pakistan
tell me again what your name was Oh my
name is usman Asmara okay very good
I I really appreciate your car and I
hope to hear from you again oh sure sure
I love this I mean bye-bye bye-bye okay
great and as people can tell you've got
to keep the phone when people get right
up on the phone like that the phone
system just cannot handle it so keep
that I'll turn you up on my end keep
that phone away from your mouth